I'm going to try something today that's
very important and will certainly be
useful but I don't know how much people
will be entertained by it which is that
I'm going to go through some of the
propaganda that we've been hearing from
Republicans who defend Donald Trump and
are of course against his impeachment
conviction in the current Senate
impeachment trial and bear with me
because I do think this is going to shed
a ton of light on what we've been seeing
and it's also going to show you how the
pro Trump right is developing their
strategy around dis informing the public
on the impeachment of Donald Trump and
what we saw during the Senate
impeachment trial is that during the
breaks when they have these 15 to 45
minute breaks in the proceeding senators
and members of the House will sometimes
talk to the press and basically the term
Gish Gallup is representative of what
we've been seeing in the Senate trial
from Donald Trump's lawyers and also
outside of it from Republican lawmakers
during these little press avails Gish
Gallup is defined as a technique used
during debate that focuses on
overwhelming an opponent with as many
arguments as possible without regard for
the accuracy or the strength of those
arguments so during the presentations by
Donald Trump's lawyers over the last
couple of days the attorneys will get up
there and they'll say there was no
pressure on the Ukrainian president
because he said there was no pressure
but anyway the military aid was released
and abuse of power isn't an impeachable
offense and there's no crime and Adam
Schiff won't testify and they had secret
basement meetings and we have no
first-hand testimony and back in 1996
when Bill Clinton was being impeached
Jerry Nadler said this thing or that
thing or whatever the case may be it's
so much and the way that it's supposed
to work on you and it is working on a
lot of people is that you say wow that's
a lot I guess they're right I don't know
how those things are related because
they're not of course I don't know how
those things are relate to the
impeachment of Donald Trump because they
don't but it sounds overwhelming that's
a lot of stuff I guess Donald Trump
isn't guilty of any kind of wrongdoing
and this has been a huge challenge to us
in covering the Senate trial live
because it's impossible to go point by
point
without than missing a ton of stuff that
they continue to say so let's try just
one of these in detail we'll go through
what was said this example is
congresswoman Elise Stefanik she's a
Republican from New York during about
one of these breaks in the proceedings
yesterday a reporter asks a question and
she jumps in with some Gish gallop and
note that Donald Trump retweeted this
video of Elise Stefanik he loves it but
it's just nonsense take a look at the
clip dance tie this security assistance
to pressure Ukraine to investigate but
that's okay he did not because the aid
was released to Ukraine and there was no
investigation and the resident the
president has said that he did not try
there was no conditionality Gordon
Solomon in fact testified and we saw
that played out as the president's
defense he made the case that it was
presumption assumption and guesswork so
the facts of this case remain the same
in that we have more security assistance
for Ukraine much more than during the
Obama administration and there was in
fact no investigation into the Biden's
but this was Adam Schiff choice cat oh
yeah - if Adam Schiff Adam Schiff is
clearly scared that his case is so weak
Adam Schiff made the decision to
withdraw the subpoena this isn't an
unfair unconstitutional and half-baked
set of impeachment articles that was
sent over to the Senate so that's a ton
of stuff and it sounds so open-and-shut
it sounds so overwhelming how could she
possibly be wrong about what she's
saying but let's break it down with the
transcript on the screen the reporter
asks if the President did tie the
security assistance to pressure Ukraine
to investigate Biden that's okay so she
mentions that the aid was released but
the thing is it was eventually released
because this became a scandal and they
realized it so yes they released the
aide but that's not exculpatory she says
the aide was released to say that's
exculpate ori they released the aide
because they got caught and they said we
better release this aid because it's
starting to look really really bad then
she says Trump said there was no
conditionality well that's what's being
debated here her saying there was no
conditionality doesn't make it true
her saying Trump's opinion is there was
no conditionality also doesn't make it
true she's asserting an opinion as a
fact after saying something that is not
actually exculpatory she then says
Gordon Sandlin testified and Trump's
defense team says it was presumption
assumption and guesswork remember that
is not a fact she says the people being
paid to defend Donald Trump his lawyers
are attacking Gordon sunland's testimony
is merely speculative if you go and look
at sunland's testimony he says very
clearly there was a quid pro quo with
regard to the announcement of
investigating Joe Biden and I infer that
there was likely one for military aid
although he can't say for sure you can
disagree with Sunland you can think
Sunland is wrong that he's mistaken
that he's lying even but she states the
argument of trumps lawyers as fact
there's a debate about that she throws
it into the Gish galavis fact then she
says we now have more assistance from
Ukraine than under the Obama
administration again that is not
evidence for or against wrongdoing when
it comes to the impeachment articles the
total aid amounts to different countries
go up and down for a bunch of different
reasons over time it is a non sequitur
she then says there didn't end up being
an investigation into the Biden's this
is both irrelevant if you fail to secure
the smear investigation you wanted
you're not less guilty you just failed
but more importantly witnesses have said
Trump didn't care about the
investigation happening he only cared
about the investigation being announced
so saying there was no investigation
that is not exculpatory okay
then she switches altogether and this is
where it really escalates after being
asked about the john bolton subpoena
she says Adam Schiff is scared that's
not an assertion of any kind of actual
fact that's been presented she's using
it as an ad hominem she's alleging fear
as an ad hominem and then she says
Schiff decided not to subpoena John
Bolton implying that the testimony of
John Bolton wouldn't help Schiff and
that's why she decided not to issue
the subpoena now in reality they didn't
subpoena john bolton because due to the
obstruction of the white house it could
take a year for the forcing of that
subpoena to go through the judiciary and
by then it would be after the November
election and this entire thing would
have gone nowhere it's not evidence one
way or the other about Donald Trump's
guilt that Adam Schiff decided not to
issue a subpoena for john bolton
and then again a non-sequitur she goes
to this is an unfair unconstitutional
impeachment that is not true whether
it's unfair Senate Republicans can vote
and it's certainly not unconstitutional
so notice how it started with a question
would it be okay for Donald Trump to tie
military aid to Ukraine to an
investigation of Joe Biden she gift
Caliph's herself all the way to the
entire thing is unconstitutional if you
just casually watch those 53 seconds of
Elise Stefanik without really thinking
through each piece it does sound like
wow that's an overwhelming amount of
stuff that she said Trump must be
innocent because look at all those
things that she said when you break it
down there is no substance to what she
says it's conjecture speculation
mischaracterizations and complete
misdirection two irrelevant non
sequiturs we could do that with almost
any clip of these republicans talking to
the press during the breaks this is just
one clip imagine what there would be if
you looked at others let's do one more
briefly we won't do it in as much detail
because this relates to witnesses in the
trial the new line from Republicans
about bringing in witnesses like john
bolton is will decide whether we need to
hear more after the trial is basically
done and this is actually evil genius
republicans have done something insane
to begin with which is they decided at
the beginning we won't decide now about
him about witnesses to impeachment or
documents or audio-visual records in a
normal trial at the start of the trial
it's determined who is on your witness
list what evidence do you plan to
introduce and then both sides get to
prepare their case on the basis of who's
going to be testifying republicans
successfully pushed off debating
witnesses until after each
side gets 24 hours to present and
senators get 16 hours to ask questions
so now they're using this line listen to
Republican senator John Barrasso here
cuz we're gonna decide Friday on
witnesses but it's not going to be a
one-sided issue we have another day we
have this evening tomorrow for the
president's case to be presented we have
16 hours of questioning on Thursday
Wednesday and Thursday and then
ultimately we the question will come
have we heard enough are we ready to go
to final judgment or do we need to hear
from more people if we need to hear from
more people it's going to be a group of
individuals but 51 senators will make
that decision on Friday and not before
Friday he's saying listen we've had all
this questioning right we've done so
much we're gonna do 24 hours for the
Manatee impeachment managers 24 hours
for Trump's defense 16 hours of
questions that's 64 hours after 64 hours
will decide whether we've heard enough
or whether we need to hear from more
people this is a completely different
framing now before the trial which is
when they should discuss witnesses you
can't use the argument they're now using
we have a trial who are the witnesses
well you're going to decide based on
whether you want to hear more they are
going to say 64 hours is a long time
we've had presentations we've had
questions we don't really need more
stuff now it's already gone on too long
because they blocked the decision about
witnesses from the start it's incredibly
disingenuous it's completely
propagandistic and I hope that this is
useful to people in the audience in
understanding how to break down the
propaganda and when the Gish Gallup is
so frequently used the best thing to do
is convert it into writing like we did
and then go through it piece by piece
evaluating each piece taken all together
they want it to sound overwhelmingly
exculpatory when you break it down as we
did with Elise Stefanik you realize
there's nothing there there are non
exculpatory statements made as if they
were exculpatory there is speculation
and there are completely unrelated
issues brought up like when
would it be okay to tie military aid to
a public announcement of an
investigation into Joe Biden she ends up
at this entire thing is unconstitutional
let me know what you think about these
breakdowns we have a very special thing
going on this weekend it is my birthday
on Sunday we are doing a huge membership
discount on my birthday if you want to
be notified about it get on our mailing
list by signing up at david pakman.com
you just put in your email address very
easy you'll be on the mailing list
Sunday you will get an email with this
disgusting
membership discount it I can't even tell
you what it is because it makes me feel
ill it's such a huge discount but I
invite you to partake just get on our
mailing list and you'll be notified on
Sunday this episode is sponsored by blue
chew one of the things I make a priority
on the show is not to perpetuate stigma
for things that don't deserve it we've
talked about mental health we've talked
about many things where we should all
just be respectful adults period and we
would be better off and blue two can
increase performance and give you that
extra confidence you may be looking for
blue to calm blue like the color blue is
the first chewable with the same
fda-approved ingredient as in Viagra and
Cialis it can be taken day or night even
on a full stomach since it's chewable it
works twice as fast as a pill whenever
the opportunity arises blue chew is
prescribed online by licensed doctors
you don't have to go to a doctor's
office you don't have to wait in line at
a pharmacy it ships right to your door
in a discreet package they're made in
the USA and since blue two prepares and
ships direct it's cheaper than a
pharmacy and best of all no more
awkwardness we've got a special deal for
our viewers and listeners go to blue
shoe com get your first shipment free
when you use our promo code Pakman
that's PA que ma n pages $5 shipping
that's blue2 dot-com promo code Pakman
to try it totally free blue chew is the
better cheaper faster choice and we
thank them for sponsoring the David
Pakman show